Leslie I saw your Instagram yesterday
that says this is a Disney movie I never
dreamed I've never dared to dream yeah
what does this feel like having Hamilton
be part of Disney now I'd say this the
first thing that I was struck with I
don't want to I don't want to make it
trivial you know I said to Tommy
there was a there was a line never seen
the show you know so so I was taking in
a lot in my first view and I've only
seen it now once I said to him the first
thing was as you know is the father of a
daughter I know how hard it is to find
entertainment to find media that
reflects her back in the way that I see
her the way that her mother sees her
beautiful competent the center of her
own narrative you know we don't there's
not a lot of entertainment that's out
there that exists in that way a lot of
times for black kids for little kids of
color they have to imagine themselves as
the little white kid or the ancillary
character you know they're very rarely
the center of their narrative and so I
just think Tommy and I think Lynn for
assuring these images these powerful
images of beautiful black and brown
people that are going to add - you know
they're they're not added to the Canon
of film history you know for all time
the little kids will get to watch
themselves be the center of other
narrative of any story good good yeah I
mean I saw both people replying to both
Jasmine and Rene your post about it and
saying oh you Disney Princesses like
really well yeah what you're actually
hearing something like that let me tell
you it is I'm constantly surprised how
long God's game is in that I could
become a Disney princess finally I had I
had you know that that was always you
know I'm not gonna lie I mean I have II
I have a daughter too and and she's
already dreaming of being a Disney
princess so it starts I think earlier
than we can even remember but it's never
too late you know too late so I'm I'm
thrilled
and yeah judgment you can weigh in on
that as well but I also wanted to ask
you too about the fact that you met
Anthony on this like watching this now
is this like a bit of a time capsule for
relational like how do you look at it
like in that kind of regard it is crazy
too
I mean this show it's it's such a
special show to all of us but very
special to us because that's how we met
you know in rehearsals writing songs
together and everybody asking like are
you guys together I don't know it's such
a beautiful moment in time and you know
I first day of rehearsal he sat right
next to me
and that was it you know and the whole
thing blossomed from there and it was a
beautiful show but also a beautiful
relationship that came out of it as well
so it's very very special it's a very
very special thing you know not many who
can see back you know yeah and I've been
listening to the sound check for years I
love all the songs I love satisfied a
little of your rap Renee but let's say I
got to tell you like when you know those
songs that you're at the gym and you
need something like a pick-me-up that's
a room where it happens does to me what
I need that pick-me-up I put that song
on and it gets gets me going and
whenever you talk to [ __ ] with this
song this song has become a pop culture
phenomenon like just don't just talk me
like how this song has become so cute
I'll tell you this a break breaking
snooze right here I did not like that
song when I first looked because you
know I heard I heard satisfied
I'd heard my shot I'd heard these so you
know he's satisfied was a revelation to
me you know and so I knew that Lynn was
gonna write burr something he was gonna
you know and I got this demo that was
like but you know we just I trusted I
trusted Lynne I try
did his his brain and I just kept
looking at it you know I just kept
looking at it investigating it and and
and digging and we found you know we
found something very very special and I
think Tommy's preserved it so
magnificently you know because there's a
little there's a whole lot on the on the
album you just hear you just hear lacks
work my work Lynn's work but with this
film you get to see any blank ambulance
choreography how Binkley's lighting halt
as well as costumes the dancers which is
incredible yeah well I like I said if
you listen to the soundtrack for years
so I can't wait to see with my eyes see
you guys perform this so thank you very
much it's awesome to talk to you guys